diagnostic et l'asthme chez les enfants
n'est pas une mince affaire
je peux vous dire que de larges de 2 à
80 n'étaient souvent l'urgence le la
salle est pas bien la cortisone ventolin
des fois les tests tard il avait quinze
mois sa première crise d'asthme
puis on savait pas qu'il faisait une
crise d'asthme la première fois fait
qu'il y avait été hospitalisé trois
jours
si les crises sévères sont sans
équivoque la petite toux sèche elle peut
passer inaperçue si tous comme ça ça
veut dire que nous d'atteinte au niveau
d'étude brancher les enfants d'âge parce
que là c'est qu'ils remplissent nos
urgences lyon 2 à 3 fois plus de visites
à l'urgence par mille de population que
tous les autres groupes d'âge
des chercheurs de l'hôpital sainte
justine ont étudié les traitements reçus
par quelques cinquante mille petits
asthmatiques de quatre provinces
canadiennes
de 1990 à 2013 en utilisant des données
administratives comme celle de la ram qu
il conclut que les crises sévères le
mauvais contrôle de l'asthme au
quotidien nuisent à la croissance
normale des poumons
al'inverse les enfants d'âge préscolaire
dont l'asthme est bien suivi ont 50%
plus de chance de se débarrasser de la
maladie après l'âge de 6 ans et une
association entre le contrôle et la
rémission
par ailleurs la fonction pulmonaire on
améliore la possibilité d'une rémission
puis on améliore la croissance pum
honneur les crises répétées laisse des
traces
ces enfants là qu'avaient classe très
sévère en plus de chance d'avoir la
maladie pulmonaire obstructive chronique
hamadi des fumeurs sans voir fumer donc
l'on se rend compte que la cicatrice est
arrivé très tôt dans l'enfance et se
croiser les bras en disant on va
attendre de voir ce qui s'y passe des
programmes hamp une bonne idée ça vaut
plus la peine d'attendre six ans pour
dire on va traiter il faut vraiment
vraiment il ya des précautions à chaque
jour je me suis inventé le gie glace on
arrive à beaucoup mieux contrôler avec
des pompes comme le fleuve à sur une
base quotidienne ventolin on a réussi
surtout à mieux reconnaître les
symptômes
encore faut-il être en mesure de poser
le bon diagnostic chez les plus petits
ce que permet maintenant le test dossier
ou mitry fait sur un appareil plus
compacts comme celui-ci docteur ducharme
aimerait en voir dans toutes les
cliniques de médecine familiale ici à
nourrice des tati radio canada montréal